once you're capable of handling the
pressure cooker once you're the person
who's capable in the face of the
uncomfortable you can now be the person
who helps those that aren't and that's
why I call everyone out there right now
in the face of this who's been affected
who sees it happening there's this
moment in time to do something if you
are capable in the face of being
uncomfortable right now
it's your duty to help burden the weight
of others so I wanted to talk about
something here I think it's very
appropriate in in light of the current
week and I think it's appropriate and
maybe not the way that a lot of people
think bullying we've talked about and
usually you only hear about bullying
when it involves some usually gay person
who's in the nightly news because they
were bullied in school by the way I
usually don't buy that yeah you've got
to be the stupidest person in the world
to bully a gay or trans person in school
I bet you they would say like hey Timmy
what are you gay yeah I'm sorry I'm
sorry
don't let the team know I'm so sorry
when I was a kid I called it all the
time because I wasn't gay but you know I
was a loser you can just find my
pictures in high school is bullied all
the time about now a little bit I feel
like I don't get rid of the respect in
the office that I quite deserved but you
know what that just them's the breaks
no one wants to go have hot dogs with a
man who signs the front subjects
I'll be fine um but we're talking about
bullying and this is what because
they've tried to accuse us of being
bullies and it more generally
conservatives of being please here's the
thing I would like to sort of posit the
reason that bullying in high school is
is so unbearable or in the workplace for
example is because it's chronic it's
systemic if you have a bully in high
school or if you have a boss or
supervisor who's a bully you still have
to go in the next day and I believe me I
get it I had days where I would just go
to sleep going oh I don't want to wake
up I know that sounds terrible oh I
don't want to I just hate in my life
going to school and a part of it was
bullying a part of it was just I wasn't
cut out for public school as we had in
Canada but the real problem there's you
have to face that bully every single day
there's no way to get away from it
that's a big defining factor for me and
bullying now let's compare that to for
example us doing a video or rebuttal
here or maybe 2% of the video is us
making light or us making fun of
somebody in a way that they don't like
the thing is that's not chronic that's
not systemic you can shut it off you can
change the channel or online you can
just click on the next suggested video
which is probably turtle humping work
boot or angry cat or [ __ ] makeup
tutorials transy makeup tutorials now we
can't use any words they're all big and
retro actively all right you can change
the channel now compare that to say
removing the ability for anyone of a
political persuasion to be able to make
a living
including the 12 to 15 people here a lot
of cut it's not myself this is an entire
team of people
what's more chronic what's more systemic
who's the bully the person is a video
that is never even addressed to you and
this is all conservatives out there or
the person who wants to make sure that
they ruin everyone's life who's been
involved with that video forever more or
anyone who might even cover that video
even non-political channels as you see
what's he had pocalypse people who just
happened to cover it we want you gone
some people were surprised at the
apology video that we issued and IOB is
rough when you go back you watch it
you're like oh that was
yeah maybe a couple of those but they
were actual jokes that have appeared in
the show you shouldn't be surprised
though why that's how you deal with
bullies I've seen a lot of conservatives
well I'm the reasonable conservative I'm
no listen you don't give in
don't well you have to push back from
the very beginning right away you give
up no ground unless you're wrong but if
you know you're not wrong you don't
apologize and that's how we handle it
and you know what a lot of people in
applies just to bullies but I would say
it applies to all high pressure
scenarios in life in general there are
some people who are naturally kind of
what we referred to as game day players
right some people are born with it
naturally under pressure they have
another level another switch my dad is
that guy
if you ever trained in a sport you know
some people was that say Tarzan in the
gym Jean on the field there's some guys
who were just unbelievable in training
but they can't put it together when it
comes to gaming then there's some guys
who are kind of lackluster you wouldn't
pick out of a lineup
and then when it comes time to perform
boom they're on it some people need
pressure to perform they need to see
themselves bleed before they get the
head and mix and here's one thing I will
say well I don't know that everyone on
this team is a naturally born game day
player no one here
and a lot of cutter officers wilt under
pressure it's why and I said this to
everyone because I know I could see that
people were scared and the office when I
walked in it's why the attack from Vox
big media it couldn't have happened to a
more capable group of people not talking
about myself because how just how much
you see Vox [ __ ] about how
behind-the-scenes all the work they put
in it's not even close to what these
people put in behind the scenes and all
of the work that you don't see that you
don't know about believe me if you have
someone on the frontlines who you want
fighting the bullsh right now if I could
handpick them it would be the people who
are in this room and the people who are
in the green room watching we've had a
lot and I'll tell you this we've had a
lot of trial runs in those first couple
of weeks at this company that don't work
out there's about a two-week about a
month mark because it's a pressure
cooker things like this week happen it
doesn't happen in most workplaces if
they stick around after that they're
here usually for a very very long time
not everyone is born as a game-day
player okay so let me be clear because I
know some people saying wow that's not
me everyone can become one just like not
everyone is born with the backbone to
stand up to bullies everyone can grow
one I've seen it happen I've seen people
in my high school who would wilt to
bullies and then he decided to grow a
spine never again I was that guy at one
point I was the guy who walked away
holding my jaw and then at a certain
point I said
okay that's not gonna happen again so
let me ask you this is that something
you'd like does that sound like a skill
set that's valuable to you to be in the
heat to be in the pressure cooker to be
in the pocket with someone right in your
face right in your grill and to feel
totally capable and by the way notice I
didn't say comfortable
I said capable no one here at this team
no one who has the skills that I'm
talking about no one's comfortable with
being part of a concerted assault for
example from a billion-dollar media
company no one okay it's distinctly
uncomfortable yeah everyone your puts on
a good face we laugh we joke but you
know what there's a lot of stuff going
on behind the scenes it's distinctly
scary but everyone here is really okay
and they've handled it very capably
every single person and not everyone
here was always that way how does it
happen
it starts with being capable in the face
of being uncomfortable and the only way
to get to that point is to get familiar
with being uncomfortable and as I have
it just takes it's like building up
calcium deposits on your bones right
you've seen boxers they do with their
hands kick bite they do with their shins
actually build it up they just hit it
with a little bit of a screwdriver that
something they come and do it like a
Pillsbury Doughboy roller I know some
kind of a roller I have no idea it's a
rabbit trail doesn't matter I'm tired
shut up the point is it happens though
over time right getting used to a little
impact getting used to the grind getting
used to the nicks the bruises getting
used to being hungry getting used to
being tired getting used to feeling
disoriented all of that has happened
this week and if you do it enough if you
do it consistently if you stop avoiding
anything other than your creature
comforts at all costs eventually you
will find yourself capable of one in the
thick of it being able to slow down
breathe take inventory accept the stress
of a moment the rush the chaos navigate
what you need to do you will become a
game-day player and by the way this
isn't self-help advice I don't like that
term because it's narcissistic but it's
very nature
this is about loving yourself for
feeling good about what you see in the
mirror what good would that do anyone
here in the face of the ad pocalypse
they look in the mirror and say well you
know what I got mine doesn't help
anybody that's all this is about it's
not helping others because guess what
once you're capable of handling the
pressure cooker once you're the person
who's capable in the face of the
uncomfortable you can now be the person
who helps those that aren't you can help
them to lean on you you can bear the
weight
for yourself but for others because
guess what improving yourself yet that's
great of course you should but carrying
your own weight is not an accomplishment
it's the bare minimum getting to where
you can burden the weight of others
that's something special and let me tell
you there are a lot of people out there
there's the burden there's the weight of
a lot of people a lot of unseen people a
lot of smaller channels don't
necessarily have the platforms that we
do or that you do and that's why I call
everyone out there right now in the face
of this who's been affected who sees it
happening there's this moment in time to
do something if you are capable in the
face of being uncomfortable right now
it's your duty to help burden the weight
of others and I'll see you there hey if
you like this video subscribe to the
channel or hit the notification bell do
it I'll wait a second do you hear that
little ding it actually did make a ding
sound I just did it would happen while
my mouth was doing it and you thought it
was coming from your computer so that's
fun also there's some videos playing in
these boxes next to me go watch those
you might enjoy them you might not don't
care